to say the newest tears of the Kingdom
trailer was awe-inspiring would be an
enormous understatement Nintendo finally
gave us a more fleshed out story focused
trailer that teased so many new
developments to the world of Hyrule that
people like Nintendo black crisis can
make an 80 minute long analysis video
covering three minutes of footage yeah
that's how many layers upon layers of
carefully chosen scenes we were given to
watch in the trailer that being said
choosing just one thing to talk about is
clearly very difficult but if there were
to be anything that's more interesting
than all the other reveals it would be
the new characters that were shown to us
in the trailer we have this goat-faced
man who I'll call Richard whose voice I
believe we're hearing when he's talking
to Zelda about link and speaking of
Zelda we finally get to see what happens
to her after her Infamous falling scene
or perhaps before but more on that later
we also get to see the rehydration and
resurrection of Ganondorf dragmire and
let me just say all hail the king last
but not least though we have an entirely
new character the strange looking woman
who appears to be blasting a gajillion
molduga's back with her own hour see I
think I've got a pretty good idea of
just who she is and depending on who you
are and what thought processes you're
coming from it may even be obvious but
before I get into my thoughts on her I'd
like to point out that there may or may
not be certain pieces of information we
can gather about this individual from
the leaked art book yes I have seen it
and no I will not be openly discussing
it in this video or in any video Until
the art book has been released publicly
Nintendo if you're listening please
don't demonetize my video but that
doesn't mean I won't give vague hints
for those who have seen the book so stay
tuned oh and please remember that this
video is a compilation of thoughts and
theories that aren't my own and are not
confirmed nor am I heralding them as
being so meaning you are more than
welcome to believe what I say or not
it's your prerogative but first I'd like
to take a quick second to thank today's
sponsor of this video ipsos I say have
you ever wondered what you could do if
you utilized your downtime you know the
time we all spend watching TV or waiting
for an Uber or working on a stationary
project like when I'm editing videos for
hours what if I told you you could be
earning rewards like Amazon gift cards
or straight up cash in that downtime
introducing ipsos I say the easy to use
online survey website that lets you earn
points for taking surveys that can then
be turned directly into gift cards
PayPal payouts or even contributed to
charity and it could not be more easy to
just create an account and get started
right now on whatever device you're
using that has a browser to start
turning your downtime into actual cash
click the link in my description to
start earning rewards with ipsos I say
today and now on to the video
in the first place and most obviously
the strange woman has many similarities
to Zelda herself especially now that
we've seen Zelda and her new clothing
and tears of the kingdom and many fans
have pointed these similarities out she
has very similar markings on her face
and wears an extremely similar headpiece
and necklace with the necklace even
sporting the same magatama tear that
Zelda wears on her necklace she's also
wearing the exact same earrings and
oddly enough the biggest similarity to
me between the two ladies would be their
eyes the mystery woman has the same sad
looking green eyes that Princess Zelda
has however they do differ in their skin
tone and facial structure with the
mystery woman's nose and possibly even
mouth being positioned lower than that
of zeldas and even though the markings
are similar the woman has more of them
than Zelda now I'm not a fan of
stringing people along in videos just to
elongate watch time or whatever even
though that is the king metric for video
performance on YouTube so I'll just tell
you who I think the woman is now and
then you can stick around for my
explanation if you so choose to
especially since it's so obvious I think
the mystery lady is and I think that if
you watching this right now were to be
honest with yourself you would admit
that you think so too the question is
how does that make any sense at all
given their rather different facial
structures and whatnot well allow me to
explain and if you're enjoying this so
far please consider leaving a like on
the video If you're looking forward to
the game and subscribing if you haven't
already for much more gaming lore let's
talk for a second about some of the
other things we see in the trailer one
of which is strangely link looking kind
of confused standing in the throne room
of Hyrule Castle right off the bat and
just like I said in my analysis video
this should be quite intriguing to you
because the throne room shouldn't look
like this at all nor should it be
accessible to link one because
calamityganon and Link kind of broke it
in the last game not to mention it was
kind of in shambles anyway and two
because the throne room and even Hyrule
Castle itself are both preoccupied at
the moment by a certain angry redhead I
think that this plus links amazed slash
confused face plus all the Sparkles
around the throne room plus the fact
that it is in pristine condition plus
the fact that there are two Throne seats
implying a king and queen instead of
just one like it was previously could
only mean one of two things one this is
some sort of magical Vision that link is
being shown or two this is time travel
and due to some other things we're going
to see and talk about in this video I'm
heavily leaning towards the latter the
next thing I'd like to point out is the
image we have that ends the trailer
which is another one of Zelda standing
alone in Hyrule asking link to come find
her thanks to some image comparisons we
can tell that Zelda is probably
positioned over the great plateau and
notably cannot see any sky islands in
the sky above her now unless the great
Plateau is about to be sealed off by
some magic barrier or something which is
unlikely since some fans like Zelda lore
on Twitter and YouTube have located
Link's position in the trailers as being
on the great Plateau the question is why
would link not be able to find Zelda
here what's the point of her asking him
to come find her unless she knows he
can't at least not by normal means well
again there's really only one reason and
that would be that Zelda is not in
Link's current reality and the easiest
answer as to how that's possible would
be once again time travel specifically
to a time before Ganondorf shattered the
barrier between the sky islands and
Hyrule there are several other reasons
to believe time travel is coming to
tears of the kingdom and lots of Zelda
fans and content creators have been
speculating about it for a few years now
so let's assume for a moment that this
train of thought is correct and
therefore that Zelda travels through
time in this game probably to the
distant past and which probably happens
right here as she falls down in the
infamous Ganondorf encounter clearly she
then meets with the presumably zonai
individual named Richard at some point
and if the notion of time travel is true
could then spend an unknown amount of
time at his side now this is where
things actually start getting
interesting and make an odd amount of
sense remember that whatever job or task
that's given to Zelda when she travels
to the past is something that we know
three things about one it involves
Richard and is likely why he's giving
her this pep talk here or whatever this
is two it involves one of the mysterious
magatama symbols that are also seen with
sidon Tulin Ganondorf and presumably
riju although zeldas glows with a bright
yellow gold color the same color that
glows whenever highly his powers are
used like when Zelda sealed Calamity
game in a way or when Princess Zelda in
Ocarina of Time held Ganon down third we
know that whatever Zelda is doing for or
with Richard and with the golden
magatama is something that quote only
she can do only Zelda now ask yourself
what makes Zelda so special what is it
about her that grants her powers and
insights and makes her so important in
the overarching meta-narrative that is
the Legend of Zelda well of course it
would be the fact that she is the direct
descendant slash Reincarnation of the
Goddess hylia that's where her powers
come from at least the ones not related
to the Triforce and that's exactly what
I think is going on with whatever
Zelda's doing in tears of the Kingdom
now exactly what she's doing with the
magatama and what everybody's doing with
them on that note is another theory that
I may or may not be able to make before
tears of the Kingdom releases in less
than 20 days now so you'll just have to
subscribe to find out but the point I'm
making for this video is that whatever
Zelda is doing here in the past is
something that only she can do which
means logically it has to do with hylia
now if you've been here for a while you
may remember that zeltic and I had a
couple theories we did in collaboration
with each other a little while ago one
of which insinuated that Zelda would be
morphing into hylia
um behold after the passage of countless
years here is Zelda slowly but surely
becoming the physical manifestation of
God as hylia think about it why else
would they showcase Zelda's hair being
cut short so deliberately wouldn't it
make sense if they did that so that her
appearance here would showcase the
passage of time with her hair being
fully grown out as she becomes this and
as you can see the more hylia she
becomes the better she can control her
goddess powers and the more muldugas
bite the dust I think it's also
intriguing that she appears to be
becoming a goat-like person similar to
Richard as you can see with her nose
moving down towards her chin implying
that whatever race Richard is is the
same race that the goddess hylia was but
that's neither here nor there this video
was a shorter one and was more on the
speculative side but what do you guys
think is this Mystery Woman Zelda who's
morphing after years and years of using
the power of her magatama or is it an
entire entirely new character who just
really really looks like her let me know
in the comments below what you think and
let me know what the most interesting
part of the trailer was to you please
consider leaving a like on the video If
you enjoyed watching And subscribe if
you haven't already to stick around for
so much more tears of the Kingdom
coverage huge thanks as always to my
Bandit crew who make my day every day
that's all I've got for this one so be
sure to follow me on my socials where I
may just be giving away a copy of Tears
of the Kingdom hint hint um anyway this
is Bandit looking forward to seeing you
next time and signing out peace
[Music]
thank you